gardez la france au fond des yeux ligne
j'aimerais beaucoup que je m'apprête à
tricoter d'accord là-dessus à votre
place je la ramène à un peu moins mais
si vous ne réussissez pas c'est qu'il
vous manque qu'une seule chose un tout
petit détail le front fais les valises à
paris de ce qui lui arrive à la beuze
comme chaque semaine france info et
l'ina vous offre un voyage dans le temps
à travers les archives de la télévision
pour mieux comprendre l'actualité
contemporaine c'est l'inattendu et vous
êtes bien sûr les bienvenus à mes côtés
ludivine lopez gérald licorne et la vo
journaliste à la rédaction dina bonjour
à toutes les deux alors ludivine vous
vouliez nous parler d'une tribune
publiée cette semaine dans le monde
285 femme appelle un mythe ou politique
oui elle son adjointe au maire
collaboratrice parlementaire députés
mais aussi citoyenne toutes dénoncent
les violences sexistes qui perdure dans
la vie politique un sexisme ambiant
dénoncé depuis longtemps à la télévision
c'était le cas il y a vingt ans en 2001
des femmes mères en parlait sur le
plateau de france 3 lille moi c'est la
première campagne où je souffre dans ma
dignité de femme franchement je n'ai
jamais vécu ça c'était l'horreur j'ai eu
des caricatures je sais pas si ça rendra
beaucoup mais ce type de de caricature
où vous voyez je suis en parachute à
billets
à l'allemande donc je suis l'envahisseur
et j'atterris un endroit bien placé de
ma personnalité sur le clocher d'une
église et je pense que ça je vais saisir
les chiennes de garde à paris parce que
je crois qu'il faut se révolter contre
ces méthodes et vous annie cardon vous
avez souffert de misogynie oui une femme
qui arrive et là c'était c'était
impossible
une femme air franchement vu c'était
complètement débile j'ai eu ces mots des
bilans bidons enfin
alors aujourd'hui en plus de ces
violences sexy ce sont aussi les viols
et les agressions sexuelles qui sont
dénoncées par les 285 femmes signataires
de cette tribune
elle appelle aussi à écarter les auteurs
de ces violences de la vie politique
alors tout autre chose géraldine vous
allez nous parler de la vente des vins
des hospices de beaune qui se déroule ce
week-end une vente caritative bien sûr
oui une vente caritative 1 349 pièces
sont mises en vente 56 bouteille de vin
blanc pour le voulu divine
293 de rouge pour vous nathanaël préfère
donc cette année les dons iront à
l'institut curie pour le traitement du
cancer du sein mais aussi à
l'association solidarité femmes qui
vient en aide aux femmes victimes de
violences alors c'est vente des hospices
de beaune ça ne date pas d'hier à votre
avis cette date clé dirait dit ouh là
votre avis ça date de quand
et en
1859 voilà je suis sûr qu'elle vous a
filé un peu
alors on n'a pas d'actifs de cette
première édition mais on a une archive
qui datent de 1945 et qui vaut le détour
aux hospices de beaune la grande journée
à noël la vente de la récolte du
magnifique vignoble constitué depuis le
xiiie siècle par les dons des fidèles
une ampoule ceux qui veulent goûter les
grands plus les auspices parmi les
buveurs dit un proverbe dit ya d'abord
les bourguignons et parmi les
bourguignons y vient les artistes
[Musique]
on vend tracé d'un magnifique coup
derniers feux sur l'usagé vieille
province et les enchères produiront près
de 16 millions iront au bourg et aux
malades des hospices vins de bourgogne
vin généreux
voilà vins de bourgogne vin généreux en
2020 de l'année dernière l'événement
avait récolté près de 12,7 millions
d'euros donc c'est quand même une vente
caritative très importante bien sûr qui
compte et l'année dernière les fonds
avaient été reversés au personnel
hospitalier et à leurs familles touchées
par l'épidémie de koffi 19 merci
beaucoup tiens ça c'était pour
l'actualité la semaine que s'est il
passé à cette même période de l'année
par le passé mais pour le savoir il faut
regarder le zapping de l'inattendu c'est
maintenant
bonjour
il avait aussi les mac comme de la vie
de tous les jours ce côté sympathique
d'homme solide et bourru mais avec un
grand coeur
alger 1h30 du matin dans la joie et
l'émotion les représentants palestiniens
proclame la naissance de leur état si
cette étape et signe un devienne un jour
réalité c'est ici sans doute que sera
installé ici cela veut dire en
cisjordanie et à gaza territoires
occupés par israël depuis 1967
je suis très content que le zimbabwe
soit de retour par
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle entre dans l'histoire du sport en
devenant la première femme a rapporté
une transat depuis ce matin les médias
du pays font leur une sur l'arrestation
surprise de carlos ghosn dans un
communiqué aux détails accablants nissan
accuse son pdg français de fraude au
fisc japonais ce sont dix neuf petites
minutes zhang dynamiter le marché
mondial de l'art
au téléphone de mystérieux client font
monter les enchères les sommes sont
vertigineuses dans la salle c'est la
surprise générale
[Musique]
même colère et un objectif bloquer la
circulation au plus vite une
contestation sur fond de crise de
l'essence mais qui aujourd'hui a
largement dépassé cette thématique pour
devenir l'expression d'une colère
nationale
[Musique]
dans un tout petit peu plus d'un mois
nous célébrerons noël vous avez encore
un petit peu de temps je vous rassure
pour préparer votre réveillon pour les
communes en revanche le temps presse la
plupart des villes ont d'ailleurs déjà
installé leurs illuminations c'est une
tradition très ancienne et bien
appréciable oui oui c'est beau une ville
la nuit surtout au moment de noël il ya
une avenue où ces illuminations vous le
savez sont particulièrement attendus les
champs-elysées certains parlent de la
plus belle avenue du monde
cette année géraldine c'est clara
luciani qui appuiera sur l'interrupteur
et illuminera 7 plus belle avenue
exactement elle fera sa dimanche et
c'est une tradition à les vedettes qui
appuie sur ce bouton et hop tous les
champs elysées c'est clair scintille de
mille feux alors les champs-elysées
vitrine de paris ville lumière on a
voulu voir dans les archives de l'ina
depuis quand date cette tradition des
stars qui allume les champs est ce que
les champs elysées ont toujours été
autant éclairé à noël je vais vous
éclairer au nom qui va nous obliger été
obligé objets que je vais vous éclairer
avec ce dossier
cette voûte est insolente qui s'arrondit
antonelle par dessus les champs elysées
et l'une des plus spectaculaires parmi
toutes ces illuminations qui décorent
les rues de paris à l'approché des fêtes
de fin d'année dans les années 60 les
champs elysées à l'ol sont la vitrine de
paris ville lumière
mais le faste va connaître un sérieux
coup de frein dans les années soixante
dix crise du pétrole il faut faire des
économies et les champs elysées à noël
en sont le symbole les français se
serrent la ceinture les champs e arrange
les lumières au placard à une époque où
les prix du pétrole devienne
véritablement fou fou fou il ne faut pas
bien s'il ne faut bien sûr négliger
aucune source d'énergie il faut aussi on
vous le répète économiser et dans ce
domaine paris paris montre l'exemple
paris ville lumière s'est mise en
veilleuse pour les fêtes les
éliminations sont plutôt modestes en
cette fin d'année les parisiens râle je
trouve que c'est très triste qu'on n'a
vraiment pas l'impression que ce sont
les faits noël normalement c'est plus
agréable lorsqu'on voit dans la rue les
lumières alors en 1981 l'illumination de
l'avenue est confiée non plus
exclusivement à la mairie mais aux
commerçants des champs elysées c'est
très joli
oui bon c'est bien fun c'est nécessaire
nécessaire pourquoi pour l'ambiance ap
d'un bien dans les coeurs cas ici
en 1990 et départ la ville alors
conduite par jacques chirac les
illuminations prennent encore plus
d'ampleur avec une continuité de la
concorde jusqu'à l'arc de triomphe ça
vaut bien direct sur le 20h le maire de
paris va nous faire un cadeau maintenant
en direct 1 2 3
alors voilà on voit l'ensemble qui sont
ils
les illuminations deviennent alors un
spectacle avec toute une mise en scène
année après année les stars se succèdent
pour appuyer sur ce fameux bouton
charles aznavour liza minnelli johnny
hallyday catherine deneuve carole
bouquet ou omar sy en 2014 leurs marges
nrs pas cela il s'est déjà allumé je me
dis mais qui habite et cette année c'est
moi donc ce qu'ils font les
illuminations change tous les 4-5 ans
avec parfois des ratés comme en 2011
il ya soir la comédienne audrey tautou a
donné le coup d'envoi de ces nouvelles
illuminations auprès du maire de paris
bertrand delanoë mais les décorations
des 200 arbres ne font pas l'unanimité
et là vraiment la grosse déception on
s'appelle espèce de soucoupe volante les
extraterrestres ont envahi je sais pas
mais non ça fait pas très noël cette
année tout comme depuis l'édition 2018
la décoration sera rouge des lumières
qui avait conquis le parrain d'alors
karl lagerfeld je trouve ça près de les
gants et très discret fait un truc dans
un air de fête plus qu'une agressivité
vulgaire commercial à l'afrique c'est
magnifique magnifique cette avenue ah
bah oui à l'esprit de noël c'est très
chouette mais c'est aussi au delà de ça
un outil de communication la mairie de
paris et le comité des champs elysées
par exemple cette année insiste sur la
base consommation d'énergie de ses
guirlandes qui recouvre quand même 400
arbres donc pour tout le mois de
l'illumination pour eux ça équivaut à la
consommation d'une famille de quatre
personnes pendant un an voilà un
argument plutôt vers quoi on parle
beaucoup des champs-elysées elle pas
quelle chance elysées il ya aussi des
particuliers qui font le show comme on
dit qui font un show qui se donne à rome
qui se donne et dans certains villages
il ya carrément des concours alors vous
allez le voir sur les images qu'on a
c'est pas forcément de bon goût mais on
peut saluer l'effort et puis aussi se
dire que la magie de noël appartient
tout le monde merci beaucoup de
préserver la magie
cette semaine est placée sous le signe
de l'emploi des personnes handicapées
aujourd'hui le taux de chômage des
travailleurs handicapés est deux fois
plus important que parmi le reste de la
population alors quelle en est la raison
comment sont ils intégrés dans le monde
de l'entreprise on va en parler avec la
ligue du jeu les bonjour vous êtes
autiste asperger 1 c'est une forme
d'autisme qui implique des difficultés
dans les interactions sociales un
trouble dont souffrent notamment elon
musk ou great attenberg alors pour
expliquer votre handicap vous avez créé
un site et une chaîne youtube vous y
aborder aussi la question de l'emploi et
de l'inclusion des personnes handicapées
en entreprise quand comment avez vous
été diagnostiquée j'ai été diagnostiquée
il ya un an et demi pendant le premier
confinement
ça faisait évidemment des années enfin
je suis né autistes c'est pas une
maladie qui vous tombent dessus et ce
n'est pas mal du tout court et j'ai eu
besoin de me faire diagnostiquer parce
que c'était devenu compliqué en
entreprise et que je voulais que pouvoir
annoncer clairement mon diagnostic pour
voiture moyenne un coming-out
complètement je pars de coming out
autistique donc l'idée c'est de que les
gens osent prendre la parole avec leur
entourage ont pris auprès de leurs
manager aux employeurs ludivine depuis
quand l'emploi des personnes handicapées
est un sujet dans la société française
on en parle depuis les années 1920 après
la première guerre mondiale n'est pas
voulait absolument réintégrer les
mutilés de guerre sur le marché du
travail une loi dans ce sens est votée
en 1924 elle était exclusivement réservé
aux gueules cassées à l'époque elle
imposait déjà un quota de 10 % de
travailleurs handicapés aux entreprises
mais aucune sanction n'était prévu si
l'objectif n'était pas atteint alors
pour convaincre les sociétés d'embaucher
des personnes handicapées des clips des
campagnes des films de sensibilisation
était diffusé à la télé avec ce message
oui les handicapés peuvent travailler
est-ce que je peux regarder ce crochet
vos pensées opéré avec ça j arrive à
bien à l'école le difficile de faire
fonctionner cette perceuse sans les deux
mains je vous assure que je peux réussir
tous placés là par hexion le plateau de
façon à voir le manchon juste sous la
mèche
ou huile et la mèche avec son pinceau
seulement vous ne pourrez jamais tenir
le pinceau ou avec photo mais si je vous
assure ah oui et ben voyons
oui ça va
alors à cette époque quand on parlait
handicap et emploi c'était
principalement par le biais des
handicaps moteurs ce qui était visible
cette réalité va perdurer est ce qu'elle
vaut toujours aujourd'hui l'avis du jury
oui parce que quand vous quand on vous
dit handicapé tout de suite vous pensez
fauteuil roulant comme comme tout le
monde ou la canne blanche alors que les
handicaps invisibles recouvre 80 % de
l'ensemble des ans 80 pour 80 versant
donc il ya 20% des handicaps qui sont
visibles 80 qui sont invisibles sachant
que le handicap invisible ça va être des
maladies chroniques comme un cancer une
sclérose en plaques diabète tous les to
les dys dyslexie dyspraxie qu
dyscalculiques l'autisme l'autisme aussi
et puis donc il ya vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup de handicaps invisibles qui par
définition ne se voyant pas
n'est pas forcément considérée par
l'employeur employeurs et même par un
vos concitoyens ludivine vous vous
parlez de cette loi de 1924 qui imposait
aux entreprises à quota de travailleurs
handicapés 1 10% si les 28 escale eu un
impact sur les employeurs à l'époque pas
vraiment l'obligation d'embaucher un des
personnes handicapées était loin d'être
respectée à l'époque alors en 1957
nouvelle loi le quota reste à 10% mais
il est élargi à tous les travailleurs à
l'ensemble des travailleurs handicapés
plus seulement aux mutilés de guerre
mais là encore pas de sanction et
l'emploi des personnes en situation de
handicap reste difficile au début des
années 80 beaucoup ne trouvait toujours
pas de travail écoutez le témoignage de
cet homme amputé d'une jambe j'ai été
reçu par la sncf dans un premier temps
tout s'est bien passé mais à l'issue
d'un second entretien
ayant remarqué que j'étais handicapé on
m'a refusé le droit de passer les tests
comme tous les gens qui étaient en même
temps que moi qui étais là pour quêter
donc des concurrents et on vous a
proposé un emploi pourtant on m'a pas
proposé quelque chose qu'on m'a plutôt
maputo dit vous ne pouvez pas rentrer
alors cet homme vous le précisez était
diplômé d'une école de commerce il
parlait plusieurs langues pourtant c'est
son handicap qui a pesé dans la balance
au moment de son entretien d'embauché
plutôt que ses compétences c'est la
discrimination c'est la vie aucun aucun
métier n'est aucun angle icap est
incompatible avec aucun métier c'est la
limite médicale du salarié qui vont
faire qu'il peut ou pas accéder à tel
métier mais effectivement c'est pas
parce qu'on a une jambe au moins qu'on a
des neurones en moins et donc il ya
forcément une personne entreprise
quelque part et est-ce que voir la
personne handicapée plutôt que le
travailleur est ce que cette vision là
est-ce qu'elle a évolué ou pas pas trop
pas encore cessé en route mais pas
complètement le premier handicap qu'on
va avoir ça va être l'entretien
d'embauché par exemple quand on a un
handicap invisible et surtout quand en
étant autistes je parle donc je connais
de ce que je connais
passer un premier entretien en physique
alors que 80% des messages sont non
verbaux c'est compliqué ne sachant pas
comprendre l'implicite l'intuitif les
sous-entendus les non-dits la posture
physique les gestes qui pourraient
m'orienter vers telle ou telle
pensée de la personne que j'ai en face
de moi moi je suis absolument incapable
donc j'apprends des scripts de
d'entretien d'embauché et je réponds à
la bonne question au bon moment et quand
il ya une question qui fait pas partie
de mon script bon c'est un peu la
catastrophe parce que l'inattendu est
vraiment compliqué à gérer quand on est
autiste alors en 1987 livini à une
avancée législative majeure en matière
d'emploi des personnes handicapées oui
elle est le quota de 10 pour ça je l' ai
dit tout à l'heure très peu respectés
revu à la baisse désormais les
entreprises de plus de 20 salariés
doivent embaucher au minimum 6 % de
travailleurs handicapés
celles qui résistent seront sanctionnés
c'est ça la nouveauté elles devront
payer une amende une contribution au
fonds dead des handicapés mais certains
patrons préfèrent payer cette
contribution cette amende plutôt que
d'embaucher des personnes en situation
de handicap c'était le cas de ce chef
d'entreprise en 1997 ça fait combien de
temps que vous payez la contribution
20h50 an puisqu'elles vont existe depuis
disons que bon on cotise ans cotisent
régulièrement et puis bon ça devient une
une coutume on sait qu'on a ça a payé
donc on ne va pas chercher plus loin
depuis je dirais quand on recherche un
poste on n'a pas idée d'aller de se
retourner entre guillemets devant une
personne handicapée cette réalité est
malheureusement persiste encore
aujourd'hui il ya des entreprises des
chefs d'entreprise qui préfèrent payer
cette contribution plutôt que
d'embaucher des personnes handicapées
pourquoi
je pense qu on reste au niveau des
préjugés
c'est pour ça qu'il ya moins de travail
d'évangélisation en faire maintenant il
ya des entreprises qui
ne peuvent pas accueillir tout type de
handicap non plus quand vous êtes sur
une chaîne de montage quand vous
proposer des montages de voiture si vous
avez un handicap si vous voulez mal au
dos de façon chronique vous pouvez pas
travailler sur une chaîne de montage
comme ça pour autant c'est un au salarié
ou la personne qui postulent de
déterminer avec l'employeur quelles sont
ses limites et quels sont les
aménagements possibles du poste de
travail il y en a de plus en plus
d'autant que quand vous vous employez
des personnes en situation de handicap
qui sont déclarés rqth vous bénéficiez
des aides de l'état qui vous aident à
aménager le poste de travail donc ya pas
vraiment d'excusés la fiction
d'information justement pour les
entreprises sur ce sujet moi je ne suis
pas côté rh donc je saurais pas vous
dire mais bon nul n'est censé ignorer la
loi surtout quand on est rh en termes de
recrutement le recrutement ne doit pas
faire de discrimination ni positives
enfin dans aucun naissance en fait on va
pas embaucher plus de handicapés parce
que on veut pas payer la taxe puisque
aujourd'hui sur son cv c'est un avantage
ou encore un inconvénient de m que l'on
souffre d'un handicap alors moi je n'ai
pas sur mon cv
je pourrais mettre que je suis rqth
vraie reconnaissance en qualité
travailleurs handicapés ce quelqu'un
mais j'annonce pas sur mon cv parce que
se faire qu'on s'oriente sur mes
compétences que vraiment on regarde ça
je suis une personne qui a t'elle
compétences avant d'avoir un trottier
suis pas plus blonde que je me suis
autistes ou que j'ai les yeux bleus
voilà c'est une caractéristique parmi
d'autres et en revanche j'en parle dans
ma lettre de motivation en expliquant ce
qu'est l'autisme un super gars quelles
sont mes forces et quelles sont mes
limites aussi en quoi je peux servir
l'entreprise et d'en ligne des archives
que j'ai vu il ya un responsable rh qui
évoque aussi un frein à notre frein au
recrutement des personnes handicapées
écoutez c'était en 2009 on cherche des
bac + 2 et voir plus et 80% des salariés
handicapés n'ont pas le bac donc en fait
on cherche des moutons à six pattes et
toutes les entreprises cherchent les
mêmes moutons donc au final c'est vrai
qu'il faut pas soin est omniprésent
c'est ce qu'on essaye de faire soit de
créer ses compétences c'est vrai ce
qu'il dit la qualification la formation
des personnes handicapées c'est un
problème pour le recrutement de
certaines entreprises et oui
probablement puisqu'en fait avant en
arrivant d'entreprises ont ni à l'école
et comme l'école n'est pas adapté non qu
à certains types de handicap mais je
je ne pointe pas du tout sur les
professeurs dont ce n'est pas le métier
d'être de s'occuper d'enfants handicapés
mais en tout cas il ya cette notion
d'accueil d'inclusion qui est importante
à tous les niveaux donc je fais aussi
des sensibilisations en grandes écoles
et
école postbac pour que justement tous
ces futurs managers et en tête que
l'inclusion le handicap fait partie de
la société et ça commence dès le départ
de l'école dès l'école vous l'avez dit
vous militez pour une meilleure
inclusion des personnes handicapées dans
le monde du travail et avant cela au
sein de l'école la loi handicap de 2005
à l'est aussi dans le sens et plus
récemment la loi de 2018 aussi les
entreprises sont appelées à mieux
s'adapter à leurs travailleurs
handicapés en 2019 un reportage france 3
s'intéressait à l'une de ces entreprises
cette entreprise de conseil en
informatique à trois salariés atteints
du syndrome d'asperger heures l'année
dernière une nouvelle personne autiste a
été embauché grâce à l'accompagnement
d'une association spécialisée son
environnement de travail a été aménagé
on est dans un espace qui est beaucoup
plus confinés dans clash qui est très
très peu bruyant en fait c'est un espace
vraiment de réflexion ici on ya les
développeurs qui ont besoin de
concentration de calme
est ce que comme l'exemple qu'on vient
de voir votre employeur s'est adapté à
votre handicap oui et ça a été assez
facile parce que j'ai pas besoin de
beaucoup d'aménagements de mon poste de
travail et surtout été facile parce que
je suis dans une entreprise qui traient
inclusive en fait je fais une
distinction entre l'intégration et
l'inclusion l'intégration c'est une
personne qui essaie de s'adapter à un
milieu que quel que soit personnes
handicapées ou pas donc comme
l'inclusion c'est l'environnement qui
s'adapte à la personne et ça ça devrait
exister l'inclusion pour tous les types
de salariés handicapés ou non et moi je
effectivement j'ai je supportais pas
qu'on passait à un monde aux donc je
suis juste dos à la fenêtre avec une
lumière naturelle n'y a pas de bruit si
je veux je peux mettre un casque
antibruit mes collègues ont la
gentillesse de sortir du bureau pour
passer leurs coups de fil quand elles
savent ce que ça va durer longtemps il
ya une salle de repos zen d'un cas je
peux m'isoler si jamais j'ai besoin et
puis surtout je fais beaucoup
télétravail en toute confiance puisque
mes responsables savent que voilà un
artiste va se donner à fond il va être
très très micro dans sa façon de penser
alors vous parliez de l'inclusion
justement en 2018 la ministre du travail
mme muriel pénicaud disais nous ne
sommes pas bons en france sur
l'inclusion dans l'emploi des personnes
en situation de handicap aujourd'hui le
taux de chômage des handicapés je disais
et toujours deux fois plus élevé parmi
le reste de la population concrètement
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire pour que
ça change
tout n'est pas qu'une question de
politique parce que les lois et les
voilà les les préconisations qui sont
donnés par les politiques c'est une
chose mais après j'ai connu à
l'employeur a encore la possibilité
à d'enfreindre la doivent en tout cas de
payer une pénalité peut pas les forcer à
aller forcément l'argent pour sept ans
de prison du caire n'est pas un problème
mouais et pour moi donc passé
l'évangélisation puis s'est montré que
moi j'ai un handicap invisible est elle
regarde toute la société qu'il faudrait
changer au delà des entreprises autour
de moi mon handicap c'est pas d'être
autiste mon handicap c'est le monde qui
m'entoure et tim horan handicapés en
fait puisqu'il n'est pas adapté à mes
amis spécificité
la lie du jeu des merci beaucoup et
d'avoir accepté notre invitation et
merci à vous et lui des vignes pour ce
dossier on se quitte sur notre
traditionnel pépites que vous connaissez
j'en suis sûr la lie on a commencé sur
les champs-elysées en termine cette
émission sur cette avenue évidemment la
plus belle du monde joe dassin et
l'émission cadet rousselle c'était en
1976 regardez écoutez bien sûr
[Musique]
j'avais envie de dire bonjour à mourir
n'importe qui et ce foutoir je dis
n'importe quoi il s'y essaie de te
parler au cabri boisé
la chanteuse est
[Musique]
et cela plaît c'est
il
qu'est-ce que
auchan je vous l'avais dans la tête la
ligne pour cela il ya moi et là j'ai vu
nos téléspectateurs qui vous fredonnez
les champs-elysées toute la journée
merci en tout cas on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine sur le canal 27 et
toute la semaine sur les réseaux sociaux
ceux de france info ce de l'ina émission
préparée avec les documentalistes
florence lui c'est clair brûlé et mais
hong à la merci à elle et merci à vous
d'être là
[Musique]